ma vie a toujours été à pompe de fait
une famille parfaite
réveille-toi cynthia jusqu'à ce que
cette femme débarque
est ce que je t'ai déjà demandé de
divorcer de sa femme parce que je mérite
mieux je t'ai déjà du sobre
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai arrêté de
croire à l'amour est là c'est ma plainte
je vis chez elle pour toi le champ du
mou 3-1 ou tongs qu'est ce que ça change
ma mère a décidé de réaliser ses rêves
et moi le mien de venir ou du
questionnaire mademoiselle on tourne
disque comment vous appelez cynthia doré
la cendrillon c'est ça tu sais que tu
auras un concert privé de frais du
prince à ma fête d'anniversaire
je déteste ce qu'il fait qu elle
aimerait 16 élèves il est si mon père
découvre que je suis la dj il va me tuer
tu crois que quelqu'un pourra me
reconnaissent qu'on reconnaît super mal
avec ses lunettes non alors avec ses
super masque tu seras jamais reconnu
je voulais juste te dire que j'ai adoré
ce que tu as fait avec le morceau de
frais du prince fallait vierge fasse
quelque chose pour le rendre moins
craignos où peut se voir ce que vous
faites quoi elle est super cette version
ne savez pas de quoi vous parlez
c'est moi freddy prince qui mieux que
vous et plus à même de parler de vos
chansons est déjà minuit il faut que j'y
aille alors va retrouver juste une de
ses baskets dj sangliers j'ai eu une de
tes pantoufles de vair apporte l'autre
pour compléter la paire set dj mineurs
arrêtés dès qu'une femme
il est temps de paix il ma chérie
bonsoir je suis là dit que c'est bien
papa
[Musique]